you're not alone in believing you could
be the next alone true a majority thinks
they could have starred as john mcclane
in die hard nearly 60 percent of
americans
six and ten good good
see she learned from the last segment
that's why i call things out
that's how people learn how i learned
that's how you learn yeah 33 years old
yes
they think the 6 and 10 or
60 yes
think they could make it as an action
movie star if given proper training
that's according to a new survey of 2
000 u.s citizens
so we know that didn't include
a obama freak might say
yeah who put that in the script
you're out fired
up for tomorrow's show
a third of respondents say that action
hero physiques are a big influence on
their personal fitness goals
almost half of americans polled also
think they could compete on the popular
obstacle course show called wipeout
which coincidentally is the same title
of jamie's divorce settlement
but it's not just about having a great
body you also need witty comebacks to
the super villains am i right for
example
well bs looks like you bit off more than
you can chew
how about this
uh they call you the view but i don't
like what i'm seeing
that's pretty good though that was good
i tell you to freeze and not move
but your face beat me to it
it's all
cat it's all about the witty comebacks
right isn't that really what it is wait
a minute you're a chick do chicks wow
yeah yeah sure am yeah is this a guy
thing
yes okay you never think about being a
superhero no i think about doing all i
can to avoid having to ever watch one of
these movies
or encounter any of the sorts of people
who like them right
comic con is a sad sad thing it is a sad
thing seeing a grown man in a batman
suit never gets any easier
uh so no i wouldn't do the movies
because i i i'm so bored i'd be too
bored and it's not that i couldn't do it
it's that i'm too that's yours i'm too
good for it yeah that's your superpower
you're you are you could be amazingly
bored yeah i don't know where you can
use it though
jamie do you ever wish you had a
superpower what would it be um if cat
likes being bored she would love when i
headline comedy clubs you could come
check out one of those
uh i don't know i would like a
superpower um where i could make someone
they wouldn't know i did it and i could
make anybody poop their pants
i would take that over
i think i would take that over
invisibility well you i mean you could
use the invisibility
that way yeah so you got to do the thing
what what superpower it's incorporated
in another superpower you're invisible
you could put x lacs in their coffee
that's so true this is the wishing for
more wishes of superpowers yeah exactly
my superpower is to have infinite
superpowers yeah
did you ever think you'd have this
conversation on the number one
late-night show
i never thought if i ran for congress
and i was fortunate to become the
republican leader that i would sit on tv
and talk about this yes but you talk
about the poll and you wonder why would
americans want this it's more for the
philosophy
america loves good people fighting evil
true and we watched that this week
that's true right
now
if i had to pick a real-life superhero
i'd pick the new
myra flores's daughter who stood up to
evil with nancy pelosi and stood her
ground when she tried to knock her down
do you think she tried to knock her down
i could i couldn't tell i mean i
couldn't tell she was trying to knock
her down it was kind of like the same
thing she was pushing her out of the
picture i saw her put her in a headlock
yeah
stick a sticker heel in your shirt run
it i i don't disagree it's clear pelosi
hates children
yeah when she tapped out i was like
that's intentional yeah
yeah that's right i mean you know what
but it does you know i guess that's why
she has a little surgery right after all
the mma fighting she does degen
superhero
it's just about action stars this is
about dudes thinking they can be tom
cruise which is
yeah
allegedly but to katz point six out of
ten dudes in america are high if they
think that they can be an action star
six out of ten dudes in america can't
see their own
dog
you know at their feet greg but did you
ever expect liam neeson to be a
superhero and he's like huge yes i don't
know liam neeson is cripplingly
delicious
wow i don't even know what that meant
but it's okay i understand but you're
right like bruce willis was never
supposed to be an action star he was
like the moonlighting guy right i think
people think that like the movie could
make them into the thing and it gets
exciting you know it's where i i think
it's weird when like guys say i don't
remember brad pitt from fight club but
supposedly that's one of the bodies that
guys want they go right i want to look
like brad pitt from five you know who
else must like brad pitt from fight club
brad pitt yes yeah
it doesn't look like that and probably
only look like that for the one day when
they filmed that scene yeah and that's
right you know who else wants that body
every woman in america
uh jamie though i still you know you're
a very funny guy you act you could be a
superhero you just got to lose 70 80
pounds 78. yeah yeah that is morbidly
embarrassing it's embarrassing you know
the tv uh takes off 40 pounds oh yes
i'll tell you what girl maybe he's
wearing a girdle i shouldn't even
i had no idea this was the roast of
jamie
no
i'm sick i got bronchitis isn't it kind
of weird though that like
whatever it was i forgot what percentage
billy was it six out of ten which i
think is 60
yes
that's how many want to be action heroes
but like over a third of people are
obese like 40 there's like overlap there
yeah there is overlap you know where you
see a lot you feel good about yourself
is go on a cruise i used to work cruises
doing stand-up comedy not after breaking
that i was on i was on the front of a
ship on the front of an alaska cruise
ship and this lady next to me i'm not
trying to be mean but she was i let me
put it this whale
yeah came no like in the ocean this well
came up out of the water
and took a picture of her and then he
went back
like that's
that's got to be a big lake because
whales are so yeah
all right
got to move on i got a cough
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else